[Music]
i'm just gonna fire up a couple quick
questions you let me know
some quick answers okay what's your
favorite indulgence like a cheat meal if
you have a cheat meal what's your thing
um
pizza who's the most famous person ever
slide into your dms
um
[Music]
drake
okay there we go
left foot up right foot slide basically
i'm saying either way we bout to slide
when was the last time you tried
watching a tv show or movie
i can't remember
do you cry often
no
no you don't
just uh
once a month
[Music]
dead or alive who would be your ultimate
celebrity duet partner
uh i would say kurt cobain
kurt cobain obviously i mean i could say
why kurt cobain but you don't even need
to say why kurt cobain i know legend
when did you get good at being famous or
do you think you are good at being
famous
oh i mean i was always like terrible at
doing interviews um
i'm more of a quiet person so like when
i was younger it was like very strange
like i was like okay i write songs and
go in the studio and i sing
but then there's like all these
interviews and like all this other stuff
that comes along with it that's like not
music
there's like so much work involved like
you're traveling you're on an airplane
every day different city different bed
and that was like a surprise to me but
like you know
i was really
just in love with music and would do
anything for it and what was happening
was so special at the time and i
literally gave my entire life to my
music career and
here i am 20 years later
my seventh album love sucks
and i'm about to go on tour this year
and finally i'm still enjoying music and
loving it so much and having a blast
with it